Here's an interesting idea.
Why do we die at all?
Why is natural selection never
given us an immortal species?
Have you ever thought about
that? Yeah. Yeah, I have.
I have never reached a conclusion,
but I always figured you live long enough.
We'll, especially up until recent
history, only long enough to recognize it.
It was all crazy hustle.
It's a more philosophical, I'm looking
for a scientific answer. Here's,
here's one answer for why we're not
immortal. So if you think about it,
why would natural selection not have
created a creature that lived forever,
right? That'd be why. Why should we die?
Yeah. Okay, so here's the one answers.
It's not knowing for sure if this is
the answer, but this is a good answer.
Imagine there's the two different
kinds of things that can kill you.
Intrinsic Causes,
an extrinsic causes,
so things inside your body that
result in you dying, defects,
diseases and so forth, or things
outside your body, like accidents,
lightening strikes, trees fall,
and you just die and so forth
because it's impossible to eliminate
all extrinsic causes because some people
are going to die from accidents.
It would be inefficient from the point
of view of evolution to evolve to be
immortal. Because we would have
all this capacity to be immortal.
We would have these body's
capable of immortality,
which let's say would be
evolutionarily demanding,
like to evolve anything like
an I or a brain or strong,
any, any quality, lactase,
right? We, like we talked
about earlier, you,
you don't have lactase persistence
into adulthood because it's not needed.
So evolution doesn't waste anything.
There'd be no reason for that.
So there'd be no that there would,
uh, there, there would be no reason.
The argument goes to evolve in mortality
because inevitably some people would be
killed eventually by accidents anyway.
So unless you can create a world
in which there are no accidents,
there are no extrinsic causes of death,
it would be inefficient from an
evolutionary point of view to evolve in
mortality. So death, the
reason we die naturally,
some people think is that the reason
we die naturally is that there are
unnatural causes of death in the world,
like accidents.
If we could eliminate the unnatural
causes so that nowhere, no,
no time ever where we ever killed by
trees falling or lightening strikes or
things like that.
Then actually over time we would
evolve to live indefinitely.
This is the theory.
It's crazy idea is fascinating,
but do you think that nature had
that sort of sort of foresight?
He was not a foresight,
but that's how natural selection works.
Think about like if I have suddenly
magically transformed your body at great
expense to make you capable of immortality
and then two days from now you're hit
by a bus. I've wasted all that effort.
But if you only done to one person,
you wasted that effort.
If you did it to other people,
you have the potential to
create an incredibly wise
person with a thousand years
of life and experience and
education and learning die.
He also had guy so everyone eventually
would die for in these extrinsic causes.
So perhaps lot, well, no, that's, that's,
that's the assumption in the model.
If it's not,
perhaps if in fact there are no extrinsic,
if in fact there is a world in which
you're never struck by lightning,
never hit by a bus, never a
tree branch. Right. Then, uh,
then the theory is that we would
have evolved to be a mortal.
So that's almost like the,
the life that you live,
you're inevitably going to get
killed by extrinsic causes. Yes.
If you extend that life
to a thousand years,
then it's absolutely going to
happen. Yes. Therefore, why bother?
That's just living in a bubble.
Just terrified of the world falling
rocks language in the entry. Yeah.
But you can't transport,
you can't take this theory and this
model and apply it to an individual in an
individual life.
It's about our species evolved.
It's not about how you should live
your life. I mean, it's also true.
I don't think you should
live your life afraid.